[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  from reality  [Music]  I enjoyed the show I also write songs  leasing it is quick and then you'll need  someone new can you see what you see  no one will players on the radio we need  to get experiments do it again one more  family more Galileo's do you want Roger  there's only room in this band for one  hysterical Queen these words no one will  play free  fortune favors the bold Freddie  concerning your private life what more  do you need to know I make music I want  to give the audience a song that they  can perform what's the lyric  [Applause]  pretty sure that's good  my friend  you need to slow down  I just need a bit of time but if I don't  have time  [Music]  [Music]  you're a legend fresh we're all engines  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]